I'm a big believer in in in being an
entrepreneur it's easy for me to say
because I work for myself and I am
someone who likes that process but I
think most people in the world today
understand that working for a company is
very insecure position to be in you have
no control over your destiny and things
are changing so quickly in the world
where a promising field five years ago
doesn't exist anymore so it's very
complicated you've got to play a double
game on the one hand you have to be
aware of putting food on your table of
sort of making a living in the here and
now and you have to be smart about it
you have to choose the right field for
you but on the other hand you have to
juggle your large longer-term goals
if particularly if you're younger where
you want to be in 10 years I always tell
people that it sounds hokey but I
believe it that everybody was born with
a kind of a uniqueness there's never
going to be somebody else with the same
DNA as you with the same experiences
there is something that you were meant
to do as an individual you have some
kind of creative skill it can either be
creating your own business in some level
creating your own project being a writer
an artist whatever or it can even be
working within a company itself because
some people like that security but from
within that company you're creating
something you're doing something from
within that makes you excited that fills
you you know with with passion because
we all know when you're doing something
that you like everything changes you
have an energy that you don't have and
so you've got to juggle these two things
if you're consumed only with the big
dream you're gonna die because you won't
be able to feed yourself or you're gonna
be losing your jobs or just be sitting
in your room dreaming but if you're only
thinking of of that job now and holding
on to these crap jobs that keep you just
above of the water you're gonna be
unhappy
you know in 15 years you're going to be
burnout washed out life goes by very
fast so you have to think of the two
things at the same time if you're in a
job that's not exactly what
you want in life you can mix the two
together you can try finding things that
you can do from within there where
you're learning about that business
taking on more responsibilities taking
on a project that nobody else wanted to
handle and then learning some
self-reliance learning some skills as an
executive or as an entrepreneur from
within that company and getting more
responsibility so it's not a Drudge work
the worst thing in life that you can
have is a job that you hate that you
have no energy and that you're not
creative with and you're not thinking of
the future to me might as well be dead
I'm sorry to say that so even if you're
forced now to get a job at a Starbucks
or whatever there's something within
Starbucks I hate to say it you can learn
about the business get a sense always be
observing and learning and not allowing
I call it in the 50th law I call it dead
time or a live time if you're just
letting the time pass at your job it's
just dead time and you'll never get it
back if at that job you're learning and
you're observing and you're seeing about
people and connections and how the
business is run it's suddenly a lifetime
and it's all up to you and how you
approach it
we can talk for several hours about all
of these things here but it's all about
timing and and and the amount of
importance you put on things if you're
20 in your early 20s don't think of
don't put so much importance on the
money on the raise you know getting an
extra thousand dollars a year if it's
that important okay I don't want to deny
that for you
but the real thing is the responsibility
and the power and the experience that
you're learning the larger picture that
I was talking about when you want to ask
for a raise you don't want to be seen as
someone who is asking for it for the
wrong reason it has to be necessary it
has to be right you have to have proven
that you are essential to this place
that they can't get rid of you that they
need you that you're necessary and you
have to have a track record and then
it's logical and it fits and then you
can ask for it and it makes sense you
don't have to wait three years you can
go a little bit early I'm all for
boldness in that area but the worst
thing is to sit there and whine and
complain and obsess about money as if
that were the only sign of your worth if
people are giving you positions of
responsibility that's worth $5,000 that
you may not be getting right away
because you're learning something and if
you're able to stop being so impatient
because people we're impatient creatures
by nature but my god people now don't
have the patience for like three months
to go by you know just calm yourself
down and say the best thing you can do
in a in a workplace is to impress your
boss and show him or her that they need
you you've created you know in the 48
laws of power I have a chapter about
learn to keep people dependent on you a
very important chapter because the idea
is people will get rid of you the moment
they don't need you you create this
thing where they they need you you have
a skill that no one else can you've
impressed them you've got a track record
then go for that raise and get as much
as you can but be patient and be willing
to let that build
through a process